[Music]
in hubie halloween adam sandler's
stupidly hilarious antics are more
accessible than ever with viewers of all
ages able to laugh along with this
halloween themed comedy
but hubie halloween contains some
tidbits that will only be picked up on
by older viewers
especially those familiar with sandler's
previous movies mild spooky spoilers
follow
adam sandler is known not only for the
familiar faces that show up on screen in
his films
but also for having a consistent group
of creatives behind the scenes writing
and directing his comic escapades
returning for hubie halloween is
frequent co-writer tim hurley
who has collaborated with sandler on
prior classics billy madison
happy gilmore the wedding singer and
more while his cadre of frequent
directors includes dennis dugan frank
karachi
and peter seagal for huby sandler
reunites with another of his frequent
collaborators
director stephen brill who helmed little
nikki mr deeds
the do-over and sandy wechsler brill has
also brought his comedic direction to
non-sandler projects like heavyweights
without a paddle
and drill bit taylor sandler is nothing
if not loyal to his collaborators and
brill's work is a perfect match for the
hijinx required for huby halloween
yes the first face you see in hubie
halloween is certainly not one you would
expect but for long time sandler fans
it's a wonderful surprise to kick things
off
our story begins at the nearby mental
asylum where the
inciting event of the film takes place
the escape of a mental patient who's
been locked up for many years
and the orderly who comes to check on
this patient is someone you might recall
from a previous sandler film special
delivery
for mr loon e tunes it's none other than
fellow comedy luminary ben stiller
reprising his role of hal
l the fantastically deranged orderly who
tortured happy's beloved grandmother
in 1996's happy gilmore he definitely
should have lost his license by now
but all these years later hal l is back
still
as unhinged as ever to introduce us to
the spooktacular world that this film
has in store
if we've learned anything from adam
sandler movies like grownups and its
sequel
the comedies released by happy madison
productions seem to sit halfway between
genuine attempts at telling funny
stories and thinly veiled excuses for
the actor to hang out in fun locations
with his friends
qb halloween certainly falls more into
the former category but as per usual
sandler is joined by an impressive
cohort of comedy compatriots to fill out
the supporting cast
joining in this go-around are sandler
mainstays kevin james is the local
police chief
steve buseme is the new next-door
neighbor with the terrifying secret
tim meadows and maya rudolph his old
classmates of hubies
and sandler's happy gilmore co-star
julie bowen as huby's long time crush
violet valentine
it isn't just the larger supporting cast
that's filled with great comedians
even the smallest one-line cameos are
delivered by stars who bring their
a-game to the latest entry in the
sandler verse
ensuring that each scene is as much fun
for us as it looks like it was for the
actors bringing these scenes to life
what are you doing i'm officiating a
funeral on halloween
people die every day dummy they don't
skip holidays even april fool's day
shut it a few to watch out for stand-up
comedian george wallace plays the
extremely stubborn town mayor
while breaking bad favorite lavelle
crawford shows up as a hilariously
despondent farmer
in a blink and you'll miss it moment
colin quinn pops up as a heavily made-up
janitor
and saturday night live veterans kenan
thompson mikey day
and melissa villasenor are all able to
find their way into the proceedings
then there's shaquille o'neal whose role
in huby halloween winds up being
slightly different than you might expect
throughout much of the film hubie is
seen listening to the local radio
station wtch
specifically enjoying the dulcet tones
of the spooky
seductively voiced disc jockey known
only as aurora
well all you witters and warlocks the
daylight has faded and you know what
that means
halloween in salem is in full effect
in a classic comedy spin that maybe we
should have seen coming
that voice actually belongs to none
other than shaq himself
creating a visual dissonance that makes
for one of the film's goofier comic
premises
and one of the film's more unexpected
cameo appearances critics may not always
like his movies but people clearly enjoy
working with adam sandler
while hal-el's appearance provides
evidence that qb halloween takes
place in the happy gilmore universe
there seems to be firm proof that this
film shares a world with
another early career defining sandler
hit qb dubois
is something close to the town pariah
even the local kids know that making fun
of huby is a salem tradition
and a certain salem child appears to be
part of a family that knows
a little too much about making fun of
adam sandler characters
you can faintly hear it early on but
when a group of kids who've been
harassing hubie start to ride off on
their bikes
you can hear one of them yell
that's right it's yet another member of
the accursed o'doyle family from billy
madison who made billy's life a living
hell
they've somehow found their way to salem
to continue their tradition of picking
on adam sandler characters
but as always the guy sandler plays
winds up triumphant in the end
one of the biggest mysteries throughout
qb halloween is the identity of the
escaped mental patient roaming the
streets of salem wearing a pig mask
as he continues to wander through the
town citizens are being kidnapped
left and right and only huby has the
wherewithal to try and solve this
mystery once and for all
suffice it to say major spoilers are
coming up for anyone who doesn't already
know who this mystery asylum escapee
really is
if you know your adam sandler comedies
you know that there is a certain sandler
collaborator whose name has yet to
appear on this list
and for good reason hiding behind that
pig mask is asylum escapee richie
hartman
played by none other than rob schneider
one of sandler's most frequent comedic
co-stars
his late appearance in the film sets us
up for the final shocking revelation of
who's been causing all the mischief in
salem
a mystery you'll just have to watch qb
halloween to solve
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]